our Cassie delore was with country star
Nico moon at Stagecoach
you have a new track out with your buddy
Zac Brown called the heaven has a bar
Zach is my mentor I've written so many
songs with Zach for the Zac Brown Band
new music and a new baby life sure is
good for Nico so to celebrate we teamed
up with bartender Elliot in the official
realm of Stagecoach Malibu we're making
the Cowboys summer which is what we're
having for the past weekend to keep
everyone cool and refreshed it's really
easy to make at home just mix Malibu
Peach rum fresh lemon juice and
Butterfly pea Blossom cordial or simple
syrup and salsa Malu Peach is the latest
flavor Innovation to embrace a
summertime mindset for all year rounds
it's a perfect way to cool off and kick
back with a delicious cocktail and enjoy
your favorite country Tunes how about it
cheers y'all hey I'm thirsty
[Music]